tf1 20 heures avec dominique baudis 15e
anniversaire de l'aménagement du
territoire valéry giscard d'estaing
définit une nouvelle politique avec deux
objectifs rénovation de la france rurale
décentralisation des pouvoirs conflit
ethiopie somalie
une équipe de tf1 a assisté à la
mobilisation générale des somaliens le
parti socialiste chiffres les mesures
qu'il prendrait en cas de victoire de la
gauche 70 milliards de plus à la charge
du budget de l'état mais 31 milliards de
recettes nouvelles
l'église de scientologie condamnée pour
escroquerie
c'est la première fois qu'une secte
puissante est frappé par la justice
la peinture une deuxième carrière pour
andré rolf prix nobel de médecine
bonsoir on a parfois le sentiment
qu'avec ces affrontements ces polémiques
ca certitude la campagne électorale fini
par dresser comme un écran qui nous
avait même sur ce qui se passe dans le
reste du monde
et pourtant en asie du sud-est au proche
orient ou en afrique
les foyers de tensions se sont
multipliées au cours des toutes
dernières semaines et parmi tous ces
conflits
il en est un qui se fait tout
particulièrement menaçants c'est celui
qui dans la corne de l'afrique la corne
orientale de l'afrique oppose les
éthiopiens somaliens
bien sûr cela peut nous sembler très
lointain on peut se demander en quoi
nous concerne le sort du désert de
l'ogaden que se disputent les deux pays
mais il suffit pourtant de regarder une
carte et de situer la zone de
l'affrontement pour mesurer l'importance
stratégique de ce conflit l'ethiopie
comme la somalie font partie de ces pays
qui à l'entrée de la mer rouge sont
autant de sentinelle sur la route du
pétrole les grandes puissances ne s'y
sont d'ailleurs pas trompés dans cette
région qui permet de contrôler l'entrée
dans l'océan indien se déroule en ce
moment une énorme partie de poker
depuis quelques mois les soviétiques ont
décidé de tout miser sur l'ethiopie
et sur son nouveau régime
révolutionnaire des normes livraisons
d'armes ont été assurées par un pont
aérien des conseillers militaires
soviétiques sont sur place et les
troupes éthiopiennes reçoivent également
un énorme soutien de la part des cubains
c'est un peu le scénario de l'angola qui
recommence on évalue à 5 milles environ
le nombre des soviétiques et des cubains
se trouvant actuellement en ethiopie le
régime d'addis abeba se sent donc
suffisamment fort pour se lancer à la
reconquête du désert de l'ogaden cette
province que les somaliens revendique et
où il avait commencé à s'infiltrer face
à la contre-offensive éthiopienne les
somaliens ont décrété l'état d'urgence
l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux jean-loup
demigneux se trouve en ce moment avec
une équipe de tf1 à mogadiscio
les choses se sont accélérées et en
somalie depuis dimanche exactement
lorsqu'a été connue la décision du
bureau politique du gouvernement
d'entrer officiellement dans la guerre
contre l'ethiopie après avoir considéré
que puisque cuba et l'union soviétique
c'est à dire depuis que des puissances
étrangères sont dans le conflit il était
nécessaire d'appuyer plus franchement
les front de libération des choses se
sont accélérées d'abord avec dimanche
après-midi un immense meeting organisé
dans le plus grand jardin public de
mogadiscio
presque cinquante mille personnes pour
une ville qui ne compte que deux cent
mille habitants 58 personnes massées
pour écouter un discours du président
siad barré le président siad barré a
insisté dans son discours sur le fait
que le socialisme dans son esprit
n'était pas l' impérialisme et que
l'union soviétique quelles que soient
ses idéaux officielle se conduisait
comme une puissance
le niet le président s'est paré a
également appelé la population a
massivement se présenter devant les
casernes pour se faire enrôler pour
participer aux combats de la libération
des provinces somalie occupé par goût
barbe colonialiste c'est-à-dire par
l'équipe effectivement depuis lundi
devant certaines casernes de la banlieue
de mogadiscio des habitants somaliens se
présente surtout des paysans pour
participer à la libération de l'ogaden
car l'armée éthiopienne extrêmement
puissante largement armés par les
soviétiques et aidés par les coopérants
militaires cubains est déjà en route
vers les provinces de l'ogaden libéré
comme on dit ici par les fronts
libération somalie au cours de l'été
dernier cette armée doit évidemment
avancer lentement car cette norme est
lourde elle a des problèmes de
logistique
il n'empêche que pour l'instant le
rapport des forces est quand même très
largement en faveur de l'ex figure
l'appétit abyssinie pour rappeler que
c'est une puissance coloniale un ancien
empire alors la somalie bien sûr
s'inquiète de son isolement
international et l'ambassadeur du
gouvernement de mogadiscio en france a
déclaré aujourd'hui que l'attitude
française comme celle des autres
puissances européennes était ambiguë
monsieur samantha reproche aux européens
et aux occidentaux de ne pas prendre
ouvertement position en faveur de la
somalie et contre l'intervention
soviétique dans cette région du monde
paris et le désert français
c'était en forme de constat le titre
d'un ouvrage publié il ya quelques
années par un haut fonctionnaire
monsieur jean-françois gravier il
dénonce ces chiffres à l'appui
l'énorme déséquilibre qui s'établissait
dans tous les domaines économique
politique culturel entre paris et sa
gigantesque agglomération et le reste du
pays
une centralisation aussi désastreuse
d'ailleurs pour la région parisienne
menacé d'apoplexie que pour la province
envoie d'années me et c'est pour lutter
contre cet état de chose qui allait en
s'aggravant qu'avait été constitué la
datar c'est à dire la délégation à
l'aménagement du territoire et à
l'action régionale
aujourd'hui le président de la
république célébrer le 15e anniversaire
de la mise en oeuvre de cette politique
d'aménagement du territoire monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing a défini dans
ce domaine deux objectifs prioritaires
la rénovation de la france rurale et la
décentralisation des pouvoirs politiques
et économiques
le président de la république a par
ailleurs annoncé qu'il convoquerait
avant la fin de l'année une conférence
sur l'aménagement du territoire
le quinzième anniversaire de la datar
délégation à l'aménagement du territoire
et en fait marqué par un changement
d'époque premier temps une période de
remarquable expansion industrielle avait
permis à une politique volontariste
d'obtenir suivant le chef de l'état un
bilan positif freinage du gigantisme
parisien rupture de l'isolément de la
province transport téléphone grands
équipements et réduction des inégalités
régionales notamment l'ouest le massif
central la corse et le languedoc second
temps maintenant la crise qui frappe
durement les riches
pour le président de la république un
nouvel élan est donc nécessaire pour
concilier les nécessités économiques et
les aspirations des français
deux axes décentralisation géographique
priorité à l'espace rural aux villes
petites et moyennes des cip et à
l'échelle humaine pour stopper
l'immigration massive décentralisation
des pouvoirs responsabilité à la base
augmentation des moyens des régions et
des collectivités locales et surtout
pour fournir du travail sur place une
politique industrielle centrée sur
l'emploi régional de me propose de
réunir à la fin de l'année 1978
une conférence nationale de
l'aménagement du territoire ouverte à
tous ceux qui dans leur région dans leur
commune ou dans leur entreprise
élus ou responsables souhaitent faire
des propositions concrètes et participez
à la mise en oeuvre de cette politique
là messieurs de tous les pays du monde
la france est sans doute celui dont les
sculpteurs et les peintres ont le plus
souvent cherché à dessiner le visage à
ceux qui travaillaient pour en tracer
les lignes sur leur feuille de dessin
cherchant à en exprimer l'harmonie et la
fière élégance s'est ajouté depuis 15
ans l'équipe de ceux et de celles qui
ont travaillé à améliorer l'équilibré
profond de la france dessinateur eux
six artisans à leur manière
nous leur devons une france rajeunie
autre est plus régulier aux forces mieux
répartie au delà de l'éloge que leur
adresse le président de la république
qu'il se souvienne pour eux mêmes
d'avoir bien servi la vigueur et
l'harmonie de la france le président de
république a également annoncé au cours
de cette allocution qu'il se rendrait
prochainement en corse ce soir au
sommaire de notre journal des
législatives le chiffrage du programme
du parti socialiste et la campagne
électorale du premier ministre à moins
d'un mois du premier tour du scrutin le
débat est toujours dominé par le duel
qui oppose raymond barre et françois
mitterrand une analyse de patrice
duhamel
oui le fait du jour à 26 jours du
premier tour des législatives c'est
incontestablement toujours le face à
face qui se poursuit entre raymond barre
serein et confiant dans la victoire de
la majorité et françois mitterrand qui
croît lui au succès de l'opposition à
face à face sur quatre fronts d'abord
les institutions la polémique sur le
rôle du président de la république dans
l'hypothèse d'une victoire de
l'opposition s'est calmée mais il serait
étonnant qu'elle ne reprennent pas d'ici
peu lefranc ensuite à françois
mitterrand qui affirmait encore hier
soir à grenoble que le gouvernement
spéculent sur la spéculation raymond
barre a répondu sèchement en parlant
sans citer le leader socialiste du
pyromane qui se transforme en pompier le
troisième point de divergence c'est le
bilan du plan barre françois mitterrand
le critiquent sévèrement ils jugent la
situation catastrophique
raymond barre lui s'indigne d'entendre
dire que le gouvernement n'a pas de
coeur il juge les attaques socialistes
inadmissible irresponsable et
démagogique c'est le point d'ancrage
politique le problème posé sur le fond
comme il l'est sur le quatrième thème du
face-à-face raymond barre françois
mitterrand le programme socialiste le
premier ministre chiffre en effet à 157
milliards de francs les mesures
proposées par l'opposition plus 70
milliards qui pèserait sur les
entreprises
soit au total 227 milliards le parti
socialiste présente quant à lui un
chiffrage différents 70 milliards de
francs de dépenses supplémentaires 31
milliards environ de recettes nouvelles
un déficit de 40 milliards de francs
environ bref la campagne s'intensifie
sur le
thème central des perspectives
économiques le grand duel est bien
engagée entre le premier ministre et
l'opposition
raymond barre indiquent que
l'application du programme commun
conduirait à un doublement des impôts
pour tous les français le parti
socialiste répond chiffres à l'appui
en détaillant une série de propositions
que nous présente à laver l'air
ce chiffrage ne concerne pas tout le
programme commun mais les mesures qui
seront prises immédiatement en cas de
victoire de la gauche est d'abord celle
destinée à réduire les inégalités smic à
2400 francs relèvement du minimum
vieillesse des allocations familiales de
l'allocation chômage
ces mesures contribueront à la relance
qui permettra la création de 390 mille
emplois dès cette année affirment les
économistes du parti socialiste selon
eux l'économie n'aura pas à souffrir de
ces mesures
la hausse des prix sera limitée à 10%
grâce au blocage et le déficit du
commerce extérieur à 18 milliards
comment 76 et c'est ici qu'on en arrive
aux moyens un déficit budgétaire x 4
mais qui ne représentera que huit et
demi pour cent du budget de l'état
explications
les dépenses budgétaires augmenteront de
70 milliards et demi compte tenu des
mesures sociales mais aussi d'un
versement de 33 milliards à la sécurité
sociale
cette somme est destinée à réduire les
charges sociales des entreprises que les
revalorisations de salaires auront fait
souffrir face à ces dépenses 31
milliards de recettes nouvelles près de
la moitié obtenue grâce à la relance la
tva rapportera davantage le reste étant
assuré en particulier par les impôts
nouveaux sur les grosses fortunes des
actifs des sociétés et l'énergie un
chiffrage et des conséquences qui vous
le voyez sont très éloignées de ce
qu'ont affirmé aussi bien le parti
communiste que le premier ministre et
montbard mais d'un côté comme de l'autre
on peut s'attendre à de nouvelles
critiques
ces critiques en effet n'ont pas tardé
elles sont même venus par anticipation
de la part des communistes dans sa revue
économique le pc critique les
propositions économiques du ps en
soulignant surtout l'absence de moyens
selon pc le plan socialiste tel qu'il se
présente entraîneraient un déficit
budgétaire massif et une inflation à
l'italienne
toutes les conditions écrit le pc pour
subir un plan
car après le plan barre économie
toujours michel poniatowski répond yvan
charpentier et les engins jambre je suis
d'accord pour bloquer les charges
fiscales et sociales à leur niveau
actuel et je mets au défi les candidats
du programme commun s'ils sont honnêtes
d'en dire autant
même démarche de la part des deux gars
forts qui demande au nom du nouveau
contrat social que tous les candidats
prennent l'engagement solennel de
bloquer à l'avenir le volume des
transferts sociaux à leur niveau actuel
ces transferts c'est à dire les impôts
plus les charges sociales égales
actuellement la moitié du revenu
national
nous sommes à filmer regard fort nous
sommes au point de non retour qui nous
amènera au désastre si nous ne faisons
rien le collectif écologie 78 le fruit
du regroupement de sos environnement et
d'écologie 78 a présenté aujourd'hui à
la presse sa permanence nationale en
présence de ses principaux porte-parole
écologie 78 présentera au premier tour
environ 160 candidats qui ont pris
l'engagement de ne de se désister pour
qui que ce soit et de rester indépendant
de tous les courants politiques
partisans sur la foi d'une dépêche de
l'agencé centrale de presse nous avons
fait état à 13h des protestations des
socialistes du val de marne contre le pc
soupçonné d'avoir bourré les urnes lors
des cantonales partielles de dimanche
la cpd mans ce soir cette information le
ps avait plus généralement exprimé ses
inquiétudes sur la manière dont s'était
déroulé le scrutin
je vous rappelle que ce soir à 21h30
messieurs jean-jacques servan-schreiber
et roland leroy seront en face à face au
tour de julien besançon à l'événement
l'émission d'henri marque et christian
bernadac
c'est la campagne électorale mais aussi
la crise économique persistante qui ont
valu à monsieur françois ceyrac de
rester le chef du patronat français en
effet d'après les statuts du cnpf
monsieur serap qui exerce depuis six ans
les fonctions de président devait
laisser la place mais l'organisation
patronale a préféré modifier ses statuts
plutôt que de changer de chef de file
françois baud oui françois ceyrac va
rester président du cnpf jusqu'à la fin
de 1981
trois explications à cette volonté
manifester aujourd'hui par les 35
membres du conseil exécutif de
l'organisation patronale
premièrement au lendemain des élections
législatives
et quelle qu'en soit l'issue les
problèmes économiques et sociaux ne
manqueront pas estime-t-on au cnpf et le
patronat français vont assurer la
continuité de sa politique
deuxièmement après la continuité
l'autorité pendant la récession de 1974
pendant la difficile relance économique
contre vents et marées françois ceyrac a
tenu la barre de l'organisation
patronale
tout en assurant un certain dialogue
avec les organisations syndicales
or les chefs d'entreprise soit qu'il
continue enfin l'unité du cndf autour de
lui de son équipe pendant six ans
françois ceyrac a su maintenir
l'équilibré équilibre entre les petites
et les grandes entreprises par exemple
et supprimer les tensions bien sûr une
assemblée générale extraordinaire du
cnpf se réunira le 2 mars pour donner le
feu vert à cette modification des
statuts
françois ceyrac à 66 ans et il assume
des responsabilités au sein du patronat
français depuis 1936 il fera très froid
demain dans les régions de l'intérieur
du pays où l'on prévoit des températures
allant de -6 à -10 degrés sur le nord
est et l'est de la france
on annonce de nouvelles averses de neige
en revanche les régions méditerranéennes
bénéficieront de belles éclaircies sur
les côtes atlantiques et dans le
sud-ouest pluie neige et verglas en
france mais aussi chez tous nos voisins
européens
la neige et le mauvais temps provoque
toujours d'énormes difficultés les
services publics ont donné la priorité
au rétablissement de la circulation sur
les grands axes mais après les chutes de
neige de ces derniers jours et avec le
refroidissement qui sévissent est
aujourd'hui dans différentes régions les
routes secondaires sont pour la plupart
verglacées et impraticable robert werner
cette neige ce verglas continuent de
s'insinuer dans notre vie quotidienne
la première repose sur encore bien des
toits ici ceux de rouen le second
s'étend sur encore bien des routes
il aime bien les routes secondaires
surtout qu'ils disaient où sont nos bons
hiver de jadis
ici en normandie au bord de la mer la
neige a une épaisseur de 25 cm c'est
beau mais assez rare en attendant
l'hiver est bien sûr nous bien rigoureux
en france et en europe occidentale et
aux états unis et en russie et en chine
chez nous bien des routes restent
impraticables et département qui
souffriraient le plus de l'hiver sont
ceux des régions norales les alpes de
haute provence où des dizaines de
bergeries se sont effondrés et pyrénées
où il a fait moins 10 degrés et de
l'ouest mais dans le val de marne
deux hommes sont morts de froid le
premier dans une voiture abandonnée
le deuxième dans un camion et pas sur un
chantier il n'avait pas de domicile fixe
comme on dit les stations d'hiver elles
ont pour la plupart accessibles mais des
villages de haute altitude restent
isolés et bien des communes sont encore
privés d'électricité
c'est le cas de salindres saint ambroix
dans la région d'alès pour demain matin
on nous promet des gelées dans les
régions enneigées et de nouvelles
averses de neige
on oublie aussi que les vents se
renforceront enfin tout un programme
qu'il vaut mieux écouter bien au chaud
ce soir en attendant de voir le suivre à
la trace les oreilles rougis par la bise
ou bien en voiture qui rend verglas de
toute façon inamicale depuis une dizaine
d'années on a vu apparaître et se
multiplier un peu partout en france et
dans le monde occidental d'étranges
groupement au rythme et au langage
ésotérique des sectes comme la secte
moon où l'église de scientologie
profitant sans doute d'une fascination
nouvelle que l'irrationnel exercé
notamment chez les jeunes générations
ces sectes ont fini par réunir des
millions d'adeptes l'église de
scientologie par exemple en revendique 3
millions à travers le monde et 10000 en
france alors exutoire ou escroquerie la
justice vient de trancher le tribunal
correctionnel de paris a condamné pour
escroquerie
l'église de scientologie et les peines
sont sévères elles vont de 4 ans de
prison ferme à un an avec sursis et
c'est la première fois que la justice
condamne l'une de ces sectes alors
peut-on considérer jean pierre berthet
que ce jugement aura des conséquences
sur le fonctionnement de ces sectes a
sans aucun doute sans aucun doute
jusqu'à ce jour les grands prêtres de
l'église de scientologie se croyait
intouchable
dans le monde entier avec audace il
avait engagé des procès extravagant
contre interpol la cia ou l'ancien
secrétaire d'état kissinger
malheur à ceux qui osaient les attaquer
mais il semble bien que le vent soit en
train de tourner à l'ouverture du procès
à paris georges andreu le président des
scientologues du français accompagné de
son avocat et ses fidèles avaient encore
le sourire
eh bien il a perdu tout à l'heure en
apprenant sa condamnation le tribunal a
donc dénoncé je cite les manoeuvres
frauduleuses utilisées par l'église de
scientologie pour recueillir un maximum
d'argent
la secte se prêtant des associations à
but non lucratif imposture ont répondu
les juges
il s'agit en réalité d'une entreprise
commerciale se cachant derrière
l'appellation trompeuse d'église
les chiffres parlent en effet en 72
l'église de scientologie a fait plus
d'un million de francs lourdes recettes
90 % de la somme provenant des cours
d'initiation administré aux adeptes près
3 et auditeurs leur garantissent l
épanouissement de la personnalité et la
réussite sociale
selon le tribunal une psychothérapie
illusoire faisait naître chez les
adeptes des espérances chimérique
il est clair que pour les magistrats et
c'est la première fois qu'il le dise les
méthodes de la secte ont des effets
nocifs sur les gens fragiles
influençable alors au delà de ce
jugement les dirigeants de l'église de
scientologie savent que c'est leur
existence même qui est menacée une
décision administrative de dissolution
de la secte par le ministère de
l'intérieur est désormais possible
nous avons maintenant avec jean claude
narcy les autres nouvelles de ce journal
jean claude narcy qui vient de recevoir
je crois une dépêche en provenance des
états unis en relation avec la pièce du
proche orient
oui les américains vont vendre 200
avions et israël à l'egypte et à
l'arabie saoudite
selon le département d'état le président
carter va prochainement demander au
congrès la livraison de f 15 et f 16 à
israël des f-15 à l'arabie saoudite et
de f5 à l'egypte impôts attention plus
qu'une journée pour payer le premier
tiers provisionnel passé cette date vous
le savez vous aurez droit à une
majoration de 10 %
du nouveau dans les gares à partir du 3
avril prochain les voyageurs pour les
grandes lignes pourront entrer et sortir
librement et sans contrôle mais ils
devront composter eux mêmes leurs
billets avant le départ et les contrôles
seront renforcés dans les trolls
comme nous l'avions
annoncé la semaine dernière les tarifs
des transports routiers seront relevés
d'un peu plus de 5% à compter du 1er
mars puis de deux et demi pour cent le
1er juin les tarifs marchandises sncf
peu avaient déjà été augmentés il ya
quelques jours de 6%
mais dans la concurrence rail route le
chemin de fer est encore moins bien
placés parce qu'il est en général moins
souple que la route pour la livraison de
certaines marchandises pierre guillaumat
vient de publier un rapport dans lequel
il se prononce pour une totale liberté
des prix qui permettrait de jouer à fond
la concurrence entre les deux modes de
transport
la retraite à 55 ans est le thème d'un
sondage réalisé par l'ifop pour le
compte du magazine le nouvel âge plus de
50% des personnes interrogées sont pour
et 76% la souhaite cette retraite au
plus tard à 60 ans commente a cité les
cadres à devenir actionnaires donc à
contribuer au développement des
entreprises
un rapport que paul delouvrier vient de
remettre à valéry giscard d'estaing
propose notamment des exonérations
fiscales pour ceux qui achèteront des
actions ceux qui auront donc ainsi
acquis un capital en vue de la retraite
ne serait pas imposé sur les revenus
complémentaires qu'ils en tireront le
métro de lille c'est pour 1982 la
communauté urbaine a signé un contrat de
300 millions de francs avec la société
matra qui sera donc chargé de la
réalisation de ce métro qui sera tout
automatique abaissement d'échelon et
mutations d'office pour mademoiselle
gayman la magistrate qui a pris position
en faveur de klaus croissant à
l'occasion d'une audience publique
c'est la décision du garde des sceaux et
le syndicat de la magistrature auquel
appartiennent aux algues émane
s'apprêtent à manifester dès demain
contre cette sanction
par ailleurs monsieur peyrefitte n'a pas
encore répondu à andré broche règle le
président de l'union syndicale des
magistrats
privé de promotion dans l'ordre de la
légion d'honneur pour des propos qui ont
déplu au ministre monsieur braunschweig
lui a écrit publiquement ses doutes sur
l'indépendance de la magistrature à
faire enfin on en est au 23e jour de
séquestration l'anc est sûre la
disparition du baron progresse lentement
les policiers explorent systématiquement
toutes les pistes mais sans résultat
jusqu'ici quant aux négociations et bien
elle semble dans l'impasse est bloqué en
raison des prétentions exorbitante des
ravisseurs
huit hommes vivent depuis hier dans le
plus grand gouffre du monde à la pierre
saint martin dans les pyrénées
atlantiques l'expédition va durer entre
trois et cinq jours pour un parcours de
24 km aller et retour dans une
température de 1 à 5 degrés avec 100 %
d'humidité et ces huit hommes veulent
réaliser un vieux rêve
l'année dernière christian brincourt et
jean claude gaudin avait eu réalisé une
grande première en matière de télévision
en descendant leur caméra à -2 à -1
plutôt 1053 m
à la pierre saint martin justement ce
document vous l'aviez vu sur tf1 et bien
christian brincourt a réitéré dans
l'exploit en réalisant avec jacky car
gayant et jean hénaff un reportage à
bord du pen duick 6 d'eric tabarly dans
le pacifique sud et demain vous verrez
ce document sur tf1 à 20h30 commencer
une nouvelle vie une toute nouvelle vie
au seuil de la retraite se lancer dans
une nouvelle carrière complètement
différente de celle que l'on exercé
c'est sans doute l'une des meilleures
façons de franchir ce cap
mais il faut pour cela au temps de
disponibilité que de modestie andré
lwoff n'en manquent pas comme vous
pourrez le constater dans ce reportage
d'elsa fontaine prix nobel de médecine
en 1964 il prend sa retraite en 1972 en
abandonnant la recherche scientifique
pour se consacrer exclusivement à la
création artistique
on peut visiter en ce moment sa seconde
exposition pour andré lwoff la peinture
ce n'est pas un passe-temps violon
d'ingres une sorte d'activités
parallèles qui permettent une récréation
c'est véritablement la raison d'être
d'une seconde existence et c'est
lui-même qui nous fait visiter son
exposition en compagnie de la fontaine
et d'une équipe de tf1 comme la création
scientifique la création artistique est
un jeu merveilleux dit andré lwoff
peintre il a su jouer à découvrir
il se plaît depuis 20 ans a joué avec la
beauté les couleurs grâce à une amie
médecin peintre et sculpteur marcel val
qui en 59 l'a incité à peindre
j'avais ces tableaux d'ailleurs ces
graisses est offerte et ses essais
poèmes sèche là autour de 2
deux mois dans ce bureau est là un jour
elle m'a dit pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
payez pas je me dis pourquoi est-ce que
je peindrai madiba essayer face à la
serre du jardin botanique doriot je suis
allé à rioz à un congrès de
microbiologie j'avais apporté mon
chevalet les voir ce jardin botanique et
qui est merveilleux
cette serre m'a fasciné avec ses
anthuriums me dit voilà il faut mélanger
ceci et cela utilisé de l'essence de
térébenthine bon très bien de l'huile de
lin et alors j'ai fait à table aux
mondiaux qui s'est révélée pas trop pas
trop épouvantable alors j'ai fait un
deuxième tableau sur sous sa direction
et puis ensuite je me suis lancé tout
seul dans cette très singulière aventure
picturale
j'aime beaucoup new york la lumière y
est très belle et une vie très très
coloré c'est le juge avait j'avais sous
mes fenêtres le matin et ya une lumière
très très intéressante et puis qui
jouent sur tous ces immeubles qui sont
très colorés immeuble de bleu rose jaune
on entend souvent des scientifiques
quand même parler de leurs
préoccupations de scientifiques
peut-être en avez vous est-ce que elle
s'exprime dans votre peinture
ah non pas du tout pas du tout bien
entendu un scientifique et un
scientifique est aux prises avec un
problème qu'il veut tenter de résoudre
il a des préoccupations les quelques
fois même même angoissé mais moi je suis
quand je pas j'oublie absolument tout
tous les problèmes qui peuvent tous les
problèmes qui ceux qui sont posés à tous
tous les êtres humains qui pense n'est
ce pas et je quand je passe j'oubliais
j'oublie le monde
je passe six mois par an à
banyuls-sur-mer enfin pas en provence
c'est face à ces âmes bien nées les
chaînes yalaoui sa sauce et c'est un
paysage de banyuls-sur-mer au printemps
et des chênes liège qui ont été débâcle
et c'est à dire et corsé tous les dix
ans on enlève les corses beau faire des
bouchons alors par contre ça ça c'est
l'automne dans les corbières est après
des stages elle les stages s a patrie
des ragots c'est assez près des stages
elle avec ses vignes rouges et jaunes
c'est un spectacle très très étonnant et
là on peut vous voir comme n'importe
quel peintre affirment ils
exactement oui cela sied au milieu des
vignes avant de refermer ce journal
saluons cette diane aubin qui est la
toute dernière pensionnaire du musée du
louvre cette oeuvre de bateaux dont le
musée vient de faire l'acquisition est
tout à fait exceptionnel cet artiste qui
avait inventé la sensibilité picturale
du xviiie siècle peignait des toiles de
modestes dimensions et ses nus sont
extrêmement rares ces oeuvres de 78 cm
sur 98 était donc tout particulièrement
recherchées par les collections à
plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs le musée
du louvre avait tenté de l'acquérir il
avait dû y renoncer faute de moyens
suffisants à quel prix cette diane aubin
de bateaux at elle été négocié le
conservateur reste là dessus extrêmement
discret mais tous les amateurs considère
qu'il s'agit d'un tableau inestimable
c'est sur cette image que l'équipe de
tf1 actualité prend congé de vous en
vous souhaitant de passer une excellente
soirée prochaine édition aux environs de
23 heures avec jacques poulx demain à
20h vous retrouverez roger gicquel
bonsoir et merci de votre attention